الهند وصلت بشجاعه بتنويع معداتها على مدى
العقد الماضي ونحن نتطلع لاستمرار عملنا
معهم لزياده قدراتنا معا
السؤال التالي
شكرا لكم
وصف شراكه الامريكيه الهنديه على انها
متتاليه على مدى القرن 21 هل توافق مع ذلك
التقييم وما هي العقبات الاساسيه
للوفاء
هذه الشراكه وقدره روسيا لتوصيل لايصال
اسلحه هل تستفيد
الولايات المتحده من فرصتها لايصال سلاحها
الى الهند بدلا من روسيا
الولايات المتحده والهند لهما علاقه
متواصله نعم بالتاكيد هذه
نتحدث عن اكبر ديمقراطيه الديمقراطيات
العالم نعمل
بقدرات كبيره في هذه المنطقه ومره ثانيه
هذه الدول المتشابهه في العقليه تعمل
لتحقيق نتائج دائمه وهي امور عملنا معها
عليها على مدى سنوات طويله والناس لجعل
المنطقه امنه
وتدفق الافكار بشكل ايجابي فيها هذه مساله
مهمه جدا والعلاقه مهمه بالنسبه لنا
ماذا عن العقبات المتعلقه بالسلاح الروسي
العقبات
امام العلاقه الدفاعيه
نحن نركز على كل المزايا
التي يمكن ان نحققها ومره ثانيه اعيد هنا
ربما ان نحدد الاف العقبات لكن هناك فرص
كبيره جدا واعتقد ان نركز على ما يمكن
النجاح به مع شركائنا وايجاد الصالح العام
لهذه المنطقه
ولصالح
قواعدنا الصناعيه وجيشين
السؤال الاخير شكرا لك الوزير نعلم ان
الولايات المتحده تدرس استخدام الهامبيز
واسئله المختلف الامريكي هل تعرفون ان
كانت هذه مركبات امريكيه وان كانت قد وصلت
بمساعدات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا وهل تتابعون
سلاح
والمركبات العسكريه التي يمكن ان تصل الى
اوكرانيا
هل هذه الامور تحدث
وتبقى ضمن حدود محدده قلت مرارا اننا نركز
على
شركائنا في اوكرانيا
اننا
نستخدم
سلاحنا
للعمليات
الهجوميه في اوكرانيا هذا امر لا نشجع
عليه بالنسبه
لقدراتنا لمتابعه
مراقبه سلاحنا نحن نواصل
التقدم ولكن هناك
حدود وهي عدد الافراد الموجودين لنا في
اوكرانيا لكن بقوله هذا اؤكد ان
الاوكرانيين
ساعدونا في الوصول الى هذه المناطق التي
يجب ان نصل اليها وندرس كل الامور على
الارض وسنواصل
موقفنا وتقديم المعدات
وهي لاستخدام
لادفاع عن السياده على ارضهم وما زلنا
نستخدم القدرات الرقابيه
وقد قطعنا طرق عديده ولن تكون الامر امور
مثاليه الى ان عندما يكون لدينا اعداد
كبيره على الارض لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات